it's III 2019 this is one of my favorite
times of year because this conference
basically sets up all of the games that
we can look forward to in the upcoming
year not only is it so much fun getting
to play unreleased games getting to say
hi to you guys and meet you on the show
floor is always so much fun
so thanks for saying and I and it was
lovely to meet so many of you this year
of course my first stop was the Nintendo
booth I'm always such a huge fan of
Nintendo and their booth always looks
amazing and much like previous years
we've also got some gameplay so let's go
the first time mother we're gonna be
playing is Luigi's Mansion that make you
guys don't know Luigi's Mansion is one
of my favorite games it's also one of
Jenna's favorite games
my control
oh my god I need a flash him
[Music]
now I'm GUI
alright okay so we clear that I love
[Applause]
exactly
[Music]
a little bit appeal oh it's a hard I
need that we found the key I'll take
that
I can't wait for the standard route it's
gonna be really fun
okay where's my good friend for me
[Music]
but when I get in for real then I'll
show you
well I died what does he do I'd love to
say hi to your video hi you guys are you
doing
welcome to another III vlog here we are
again is that exciting oh my gosh so
many new things coming out so what's
your favorite thing you guys are showing
today oh I am a fan of legend of zelda
links awakening that's amazing yeah yeah
I played that I played that you know
originally like 20 years ago yeah and
and playing it again in full color on
the antenna switch it's like it's like
an old experience and a new experience
at the same time I made up a word I call
it in the stall joy there's a little
nostalgia and a lot of joy yeah yeah how
great we play that one too a while we've
just expands it okay
[Music]
a change on the center trading site
never did play the original ones this is
going to be really fun
Wow
that's work
oh I wasn't me touch again I look down
Oh
okay now we're gonna playing Mario and
Sonic at the Olympic Games
I saw a rock climbing wall down there so
I really want to get a chance to try
that but the line looks pretty long so
fingers crossed I can try it if not I
can always rock climb at home but now
let's leave our new exotic Olympic Games
oh my god let's go skateboarding I like
skateboarding girl where where is your
helmets
[Applause]
let's live one more event and maybe
surfing
here we go
so I've never surfed in real life so I
she's crying she didn't do very well
[Music]
[Applause]
we're going in this is Luigi's Mansion
this is really weird because it really
does feel like you're in the game Jenna
it's real-life Luigi's Mansion I know
this is I'm like taking everything and
this is incredible
[Music]
this is really really freaking cool
no way no way
hello Luigi super spooky pink yeah cried
last year I cried when I met the voice
of Mario here's a clip of that tinny
Mario my supa Peach's
iJustine look mummy team number one ever
get old and it makes me cry
brings back so many great memories just
like my childhood oh my gosh I can't
handle it okay okay I'm composing my
song I'm sorry thank you so much I
appreciate it
oh my gosh yes have a great time okay
okay sure
it's like one of those things like when
you guys come up and meet me and I see
you guys in tears like you can't
actually understand it until you have
that same feeling like this is crazy
oh my god I'm so I'm an emotional mess
right now
[Music]
Oh
okay that was really fun let's go see
what else we could see in the tender
booth so I just play tomorrow I thought
I could live the game and now I'm gonna
try to do this rock climbing wall and I
rock climb for the first time few months
ago so I don't know how well I'm gonna
do I might not be able to make it but
I'm going to try my best
[Music]
I was so scared sir down the show floor
and I see cyberpunk oh that was such a
great highlight of the xbox conference
when Keanu Reeves came out on stage we
were all lined is so long to get it
so I overheard somebody say that they
don't know how to play the demo but they
have like a 25-minute kind of little
presentation thing I don't think we have
enough time to wait several hours to get
in but
I see pork
[Music]
is so interesting I talked to so many
little kids
I love with games he played and like
this is my first game for date is the
first things they've ever played
it's
really cool just to see what it has done
to his entire
[Music]
to be able to check the show gets only
creative stuff too
oh yeah what's up guys need to it you
know moody here come by the port
neighborhood 601 we are in the fortnight
booth and I'm in a shopping cart when
people say just seen what's your job
I don't even know I think am i working
right now
[Music]
well that was made eighty-three it was
so much fun honestly one of my biggest
highlights was going through Luigi's
Mansion it was so cool and I can't wait
for the game to come out hope you guys
enjoyed the video I will see you in the
next one make sure you like comment and
subscribe I have to tell you that
[Applause]
[Music]